you've interviewed how many
mafia
people of that life i i don't know
anybody that i could i have yeah yeah
where did you this interest come up in
your life that obviously a kid from iran
you weren't watching the good you know
the godfather no but you did though oh
did you i mean godfather in iran was
like everybody watched the gospel wow
even in iran in farsi okay
yeah so yeah tell us about that yeah so
no we grew up watching that we grew up
watching all of that and then
you know
bronx tale carlito's way scarface you
add all of them up any one of them
good fellas casino there's a level of
curiosity you know what's happening
because everything in business
and in the mob it's very very similar
the only difference is if you cut
somebody they don't kill you
they may terminate your contract
they may
you know no longer do business with you
they may do whatever they can to put you
out of business which is a form of a
lawsuit but they're not going to come
and kill you right but everything else
is very similar well you heard pat talk
at the vault i mean about systems about
discipline about
organizational structure i mean
literally almost nobody did it better
culture culturally safety
uh how the level of respect with women
certain code you followed sisters
daughters
uh uh what so that created a level of
safety if you were in right there was a
level of safety
so if you create an inner circle in your
business in your company those who are
in it there's a level of safety there's
a level of additional benefits that
comes with that there's a
so that model is ran by a lot of
different people in business
so many similarities and then you know
michael and i uh there was a uh bill
mcintosh we got to give him credit
because bill kept saying pat
you got to interview michael i'm like
bill i'm not doing this he says pat i'm
telling you interview michael for a year
and a half bill from peru
would follow me asking me to interview
michael and i kept saying finally we
agreed
on my way to michael's house i was
sitting with jordan belfort in manhattan
beach i tell mario mario we're late to
the next interview we're supposed to be
there like 4 or 5 4 30 or something we
show up at 6 30 and they're supposed to
go to a church function so i'm like
these guys so mario's hey michael so
sorry they're on their way they're on
their way i'm dealing with la traffic
finally we get there an interview that
was never supposed to happen
at that time michael's you know
we were i don't know how many subs we
had at that time five hundred thousand
four hundred fifty thousand some number
like that right and michael doesn't have
a lot of views online he's got 500 000
view videos 300 000 view videos he's
done some stuff
and then we do the interview
we post it we don't think much of it
next time michael's like hey patrick can
you tell me what's going on i said
michael you're on the cover of world
star he says what are you talking about
so the interview goes on world star
picked up by worldstar everybody starts
contacting us about this interview it
takes off now it's got i don't know 12
plus a million about across 13 million
views
and uh and so that led to the next
interview and i don't know who
i think we did another part to you and i
yeah
we got well over 20 million oh yeah yeah
we i mean listen i mean now michael's
got stuff that he did with buzzfeed he's
all over the place michael has done
wired but i don't you got everything now
you got your channel that's about to
cross a million subs you guys are
crushing it with your crew
uh there you guys got that then sammy we
did the interview with sammy
and sammy was
extremely difficult to get that done he
just didn't want to get on camera sammy
didn't want to get on camera he says you
think i'm gonna sit with you
i sat with diane sawyer in 1994 i'm
gonna do one of these youtube things
now he's doing youtube left and right
now you can't get him off
but talk about that how did you go from
beginning to 2020
youtuber how does that happen michael i
don't i don't know honestly it's it's
the cra you know sometimes i i i'm in
bed laying down at night and i'm saying
what am i doing with this youtube
you know it's a powerful tool man yeah
you know you know things got real when
you said if you like that there's
another clip over here and if you like
the channel please subscribe and smash
that thumbs up what are we talking about
not only that i'm almost every other day
i go on youtube and there's somebody
else yeah you know what i mean it's like
you know it's a whole genre of people
crazy we're saturated with michael it's
really only two people that are you know
so
of course there's a lot but you know
when it comes down to this genre it's
two people i know john is thinking about
doing so rumor on the street is john is
thinking about doing something mm-hmm uh
so
no he is doing something yeah i know
he's with check mafia he's doing it but
i don't know what angle he's gonna take
i don't know how he's got some people on
his team that are quality people we've
had a couple conversations with them in
the past not today when we did the sami
interview we had some exchange there but
uh it's not going to be a camp that's
going to have a lot of people there and
the sami's interviews now got 12 plus
million views so both of them so you got
sammy 12 plus million views michael 12
plus million views he's about to cross
13. now we have mafia states of america
so it's not like individuals so sammy
calls michael out then michael calls
sammy out and he went back and forth
back and forth back and forth non-stop
like michael would say something and
something but what are you saying though
what's your point with that and michael
sammy would say something but sammy i
disagree with you and then so
you this like chess palm and terraces
patrick i don't know if you understand
this this has never happened in a
history
of uh of of uh
mob this has never happened so and i got
a phone call i got i'll tell you about
afterwards a very interesting phone call
that you and i will talk about
uh right after i was gonna bring it up
to you yesterday there was too many
people around but i'll talk about it
afterwards what happened sure very
strange people have contacted me about
this interview because everybody wants
to know and then
the trailer so now people are asking
when is this coming out you know we
don't have a date yet you know we're
trying to figure out when we're going to
launch it people want it to come out
tomorrow you're driving me crazy
i'm sorry i don't know speak to patrick
yeah it's big it's bigger than than the
mafia genre though i mean this is this
is a history this is an america that
doesn't exist i think they're going to
watch this 100 years they have to i mean
this is a time capsule this is the what
i got out of this and from the research
that we're doing from the project man is
that that this is the story of
immigrants making their way in america
you could be
the mafia is identified with italian
americans but as we got into it you
talked about bugsy siegel we talked
about jewish the the jewish immigrants
in the in the beginning in new york were
the ones that taught the other
immigrants we talked about this then
there was the irish westies and then the
the attack but nobody took it to the
level of the italians did i mean the
russians and the chinese maybe but well
no i'm going to tell you this you know
when you talk about mafia cause and
oyster in this country you gotta
understand we survived and prospered for
almost 100 years under some difficult
conditions i mean we always had law
enforcement after us
but why because we had structure we had
discipline we had authority and we had
respect among one another
and and there were some pretty
intelligent guys there you know i always
say this you know you know who made the
mafia in this country who gave us the
biggest advantage prohibits the
government yeah prohibition because of
prohibition because that's when the
money came in that's when we started
getting the money and you don't do
anything without money and you were
advocates you were advocates for the
people at that point the people didn't
want prohibition you were advocating for
the public absolutely yeah is there any
similarities to
today prohibition was in the 20s right
so now it's 100 years later
are there any comparisons today to what
the government is doing to manifest a
certain marketplace like it's bitcoin
the new prohibition like what's that
correlation because i have a russian
friend who says when the government was
we're talking about like government
overreach and tyranny and online and
everything like that he was like it's no
problem for russians we just go black
market they can do whatever they want
russians are very smart but you know uh
i you don't want to get me started i'm
writing a book i want you to get the
democrats mafia democracy because
i am telling you that our government
today is acting very machiavellian
just like the ideology that we followed
on the street and the other thing i
wanted to say remember all these other
groups i mean you got to give them
credit but you know you take the cartels
in in you know mexico south america
they're built around drugs you take
drugs away that's it they got nothing
but we infiltrated every sector of
society from the guy on the street with
the numbers business right up to the
white house and everything in between
wow and you you know this patrick you
control the unions in this country you
control the country
today
not today because they took a lot of the
union power away from us but look you
control the teamsters you got two and a
half million truck drivers you call a
strike the country stops which you call
a strike at the docks nothing comes in
and out to his point what did they just
do in australia to uh to to compete
against these vaccine mandates the
truckers shut down the roads they
stopped on the bridges they at all at
the same time they shut the country down
and within 24 hours south wales in
australia went from mandatory
vaccinations to uh non-mandatory to what
do they consider what was uh and it's
legit you call a strike it's legit they
can't do anything to stop you until
until you negotiate and they reach a
point of a conclusion but you have that
kind of power
you know in politicians you got these
huge pension funds
you know politicians are drawn to money
you know that patrick they're drawn to
money when you control that type of of
when you have that type of control
you've got a lot of authority who has
more power in america than the nea right
now
the education association you know the
country it's funny yesterday i spoke to
captain dennis tajer who is the
spokesperson for the largest union for
pilots in america 15 000 pilots it's
called apa allied pilots association
right
and he was talking about uh
uh uh the difference between union today
versus before you know how jimmy hoffa
union before versus today how different
is today's union than before has it
changed much or is it still similar kind
of influence and power good question
it's changed a lot because the mob
doesn't have the control over it as it
did before okay you know and the numbers
are down in the unions numbers are down
i think you know back
you know in my day unions were powerful
man we
look i had when you say numbers are down
i mean percentage of american who are
part of unions
one out of uh as late as the 1960s one
out of every three americans was in a
union and now i gotta suspect it's less
than temperature you know it's no
because it's it's uh 40 because almost
90 percent of all government employees
are unions there's almost no private
sector unions they're all public sector
now patrick i had control through a guy
by name of danny cunningham we had the
security union right
we had we had security at nine nuclear
power plants in the country
now in those nuclear power plants i know
if you know at that time when a nuclear
plant closed down you had to have
security there for a hundred years what
a hundred years when it was closed why
that's what the government said you got
to have security there for 100 years
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye
[Music]